unspeakable wounds you want to hide in your heart, the cherry
blossoms place
[music] I
laughed a little and hid my feelings
Don't look at the expression of disappointment The figure that everyone wants
Unconsciously captures and
breaks down Acting
while making excuses Being
lonely is lonely
I can't help but give up again and still have high
hopes for you
[music]
Unleash it to the yellow world beyond the cards you've locked in I want to
remove the anxiety and fear that block the destination of freedom I want to save the people I care about Because I
can become that kind of pain  No matter
how many times
I get hurt, it's best if I'm with you
[music]